herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute 24 stunden lang nur als
essen klingt so ein bisschen wie ein
kindheitstraum finde ich werde selbst
bei diesen heißen temperaturen mich nur
verreist zu ernähren aber ich habe noch
nichts hier das heißt muss jetzt erstmal
los und hole mir mein erstes alt und
dann muss mich noch fertig machen
letzten
[Musik]
okay leute hier ist mein frühstück ich
habe mir extra so was mit seiner waffe
geholt dieses sandwich vielleicht
gehofft habe das ist irgendwie ein
bisschen mehr wert aber ich glaube das
funktioniert mit ich bin gespannt ich
meine im prinzip ist zucker den ganzen
tag lang alles essen wahrscheinlich geht
es heute abend nicht ganz so gut schauen
wir beginnen jetzt den tag ich bin super
unterricht mehr statt ob ich danach
ansatzweise sagt denn das hat schon was
geiles
also im sommer morgen auf dem balkon
kreis zu essen ist das frühstück habe
ich werde dort kein einziges mal richtig
gesagt sein okay leute frühstücks
fertigen zwar sehr lecker also wirklich
freue ich mich fertig und dann schauen
wir mal gesagt ich jetzt ein paar
minuten bin leute nicht existiert hat
sich stunden eis essen ja als
möglichkeit wie man irgendwie überleben
kann bei dieser hitze und mir auf jeden
fall am start ist
die haben sich dieses gutes ab und so
wie sex und ohne willst das ist richtig
stark das hat mir nicht so -2 grad
kühleffekt wie gesagt die unterstützung
freundlicherweise das video deshalb
steht er auf und wurde er gehoben werden
video und diesen effekt funktioniert
über menthol das heißt man trägt es auch
seine haare auf und wird einfach
komplett unter
wir fühlen dass es echt nice für dieses
wetter da ist außerdem limette drin und
man kann das ph und kopfhaut benutzen
wie gesagt ich hab selbst testen sonst
würde ich auch nicht sagen diesem video
wenn ich nicht selbst dahinter stehen
würde ist echt nice produkt und ich will
jetzt erst mal let's go also ich habe
jetzt das eishockey männlichkeit
politische system leider das ist ohne
witz richtig kraft mein gesamter kopf
kühlt gerade tolle sache anders heute
wird richtig gut also wenn so mancher
check das gerne ab vielen dank für die
unterstützung vom heutigen video an
es gibt übrigens noch zwei weiteren
sorten und zwar an die schussen und aber
er ist uns allen drei sorten von den ice
vorstand muss alles was ich nochmal
singen und dann lasst uns weiter machen
was sie mögen mich hier zehn die
challenge ist kaffee das heißt davon ist
etwa ein café machen kann sie noch als
nach frühstück weil es ja nicht zum
essen also ich könnte man vielleicht
weiter später auch aber jetzt gar nicht
mehr erst mal ihr wisst ja ich liebe
kaffee
[Musik]
okay wir sehen uns gleich wieder leute
ich bin hier so bist du schön und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin
überhaupt nicht sagt das frühstück immer
also das frühstück das als sandwiches
hat geführt nichts käme also mal
gespannt aber fürs mittagessen
integration ihrer eltern ist das
mittagessen werde ich ein ice cream
burger essen gehen also mit richtige
feuerrotes gibt es eine eisdiele hier
und da werde ich hingehen ist
theoretisch gesehen eis also finde ich
ist es in ordnung aber ich muss auch so
was essen weil ohne witz leute weil wie
soll ich sonst überleben also klar man
muss nicht unbedingt was essen
jetzt hat sich stundenlang aber trotzdem
wäre schon besser und deshalb dieser ice
cream bis dann etliche noch ein bisschen
vanille als clown oder ziemlich auf das
wortreich sagen wir sind unterwegs zum
mittagessen ist echt krass ich habe so
einen hunger es macht einen überhaupt
nicht sagt einfach nur eis zu essen aber
trotzdem ich bin guter dinge
leute das wird geil rietberger mit eis
drin ist echt ne geile sache ich habe
schon mal gegessen und wehrt euch jetzt
zeigen als stadt leute da ist ja mein
eisberger buch das sieht richtig gut aus
dass ich auch gut nicht freue mich
einfach so darauf brot zwischen zeche
zahlen ich hab mir so einen richtigen
trick ausgesucht wie ich das essen kann
ich probiere der 2
da steht das mal über die sauerei aber
sehr gut dass wir mal auf der cep
bleiben was ist so leicht geschmolzen
als ein richtig gutes gefühl mein körper
freut sich so über dieses boot
ich weiß nicht mehr was steht heute
abend auf dem speisenplan spaghetti-eis
vielleicht keine ahnung ich muss sagen
das ist ein sehr cooler tag heute erst
mal das eis forscher dann erzählt diese
ganzen eisspezialitäten ich merke gar
nicht dass es 500.000 grad draußen sind
nicht einfach traumhaft aus heute ihr
müsst auch mein tag das ist sehr zu
empfehlen
durch die poren findig aufgegessen ich
bin das erste mal ein bisschen gesättigt
muss ich ehrlich sagen natürlich ich
gratuliere blutig songs gespannt wir
sind gleich wieder wenn ich bin im eis
kromer ich habe wirklich überhaupt keine
energie
ich glaube das ist nichts was man länger
machen sollte als einen tag die sache
ist ich hab hunger aber keine energie
ist es jetzt gut wenn ich noch eine
pistole und ich habe keine andere wahl
noch was essen heute aber das ist gut so
ein bisschen mal dilemma ich wollte ich
mal daran teilhaben lassen ich glaube
ich habe aber ein bisschen bock auf
diese kennt ihr diese kleinen
nice ecken die so mit schuberts und ich
glaube die hole ich mir jetzt aber ich
muss noch ein bisschen energie sammeln
indem ich hier auf der couch auf jeden
fall mal die kommentare was er für
tricks habe bei diesem heißen wetter wie
man zu überstehen kann es gibt ja genug
dort die wir das pech haben im
dachgeschoss wohnung zu wohnen und so
war es mir geht zum glück nicht so bei
mir in der wohnung ist relativ schwierig
aber was sind eure tricks kennt ihr noch
außer den ganzen tag eis essen die hier
meint leute die teil dürften sebastian
die ich früher manchmal essen wenn wir
in der waschanlage waren oder so davids
ich habe mich eigentlich vorher und
nachher biegen müssen einfach in dem
vergleich zu sehen aber dass hier leute
das ist richtig geil ich musste leider
meinen hobbys auch sagen dass wir was
essen gehen weil ich mich weiterhin 1
begnügen muss aber auch nicht versteckt
die sache ist langsam fühle ich mich
auch ein bisschen schlecht die ganze
zeit nur süße sachen zu essen weil ich
mag das so mal gerne aber ich fühle mich
dann immer so ein bisschen ruhig wenn
ich so viel zucker essen und ich bin auf
jeden fall diesem punkt angelangt aber
ich weiß die zähne zusammen und er ist
weiter als kommen sollte endlich wieder
zum leben zu erwecken die auch ein
bisschen eis geben könnte ich liebe das
übertrieben weil meinem eine mahlzeit
mit dir das riecht lecker oder das
bestimmt
so müssen die sein naja kommt es auf
jeden fall wissen
okay das ist ein bisschen zeit vergangen
gerade ist nämlich auch mal ins
travel.com foto online gegangen wo ich
mit dem eis shampoo einfach mitten in
der innenstadt dusche das ist sehr
lustig geworden und ich bin wirklich ein
bisschen stolz darauf und wir gehen
jetzt los trennen müssen ein paar
anderen leuten ich hab hunger und ich
dachten freue mich schon so ein bisschen
langsam darauf wieder normal essen zu
dürfen letzten okay wir sind unterwegs
zur ich bin noch mal kurz rausgehen aus
der bahn und wollen wir jetzt dürft ihr
raten natürlich ein eis das ist so ein
neues kinder bueno heißen ich habe noch
nie gegessen
klopp wollte ist der perfekte tag um es
auszuprobieren sagt wird man aber auch
taucher nicht ich bin froh wenn ich
wieder essen darf noch mal warum
recruiter tag keine ahnung das war echt
so ein bisschen lesungen kleiner
kindheitstraum tag als es mir schon gut
wir sind jetzt wieder zu hause ich habe
nichts mehr gegessen außer dem eiscafé
eben leute ich bin übertrieben hungrig
gefühlt komplett überzuckert also so ein
bisschen aufgedreht und ich freue mich
darauf normale sachen zu essen aber ich
gehe schlafen
es ist der nächste morgen ich dachte der
essen ich freue mich wirkt ein bisschen
darauf ich würde sagen an der stelle
aber endlich auch das video es war sehr
etwas haben vier sondern nur ein eis zu
essen ich sage nochmal ein großes
dankeschön an garnier für die
unterstützung vom heutigen video grafik
ein cooler partner und insbesondere in
sydney müsste wirklich abschrecken das
super lustig geworden schreibt mal es in
die kommentare wenn ihr von diesem
youtube video kommt jetzt noch dabei und
auch instagram würde ich sagen sehen uns
beim nächsten video wieder haut rein
macht es gut und bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]